جميع وصفه وزير الخارجيه التركيه موجود شو
اغلق قرار المدعي العام السعودي عدم
محاكمه المشاركين في مظاهره وصفها
بالعنصريه بانه قرار سخيف ودعى السويد
للالتزام بتعهدات مكافحه الارهاب التي
قطعتها على نفسها جاء ذلك خلال المؤتمر
الصحفيين لوزير التركي مع فضيله الايرانيه
حسين امير عبد الحيان العاصمه التركيه
انقره
ساندرياس
كلنا نعرف ماذا يعني مبدا سياده القانون
فالمتظاهرون ارهابيون تظاهروا للترويج
للارهاب السلطات السويديه تقولون
المظاهرات تندرج في اطار حريه التعبير رغم
ادراكها امام مظاهره تتضمن الكراهيه
والعنصريه الممنوعه قانون في السويد فضلا
عن انهما ممنوعتان في المقاييس والقوانين
العالميه ايضا اقول للسويد ان عليها ان لا
تمطرنا من خلال التلاعب بالكلمات
الارهابيين او ان تضع نصب عينيها اولويات
بامن لنا جميعا